hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer weiteren mord review und zwar
heute von dem paintball bot der auch für
die 14.6 gebettet ist ihr braucht dafür
wie immer vor installation ist ganz
einfach einfach paintball dort zip
ordner in den mods ordner der generiert
wenn ihr forge installiert habt werden
wenn ihr nicht wisst was fortschritt ich
habe dazu auch ein tutorial mal gemacht
also einfach auf meinen kanal nach vorn
suchen
und ja also ich würd sagen ich fange
direkt an weil dieser mod ist sehr
umfangreich und ich versuche das alles
hier so kurz wie nur eben möglich zu
halten
ich habe hier schon so eine kleine
fläche aufgebaut mit ein paar opfern
also mit ein paar schafen
hier seht ihr schon so ein häuschen und
zwar wenn im inventar seit sie das alles
ja so aus allerdings könnt ihr oben
jetzt auf weiter klicken und das hier im
moment darauf paintball und das hier
sind alle sachen durch im paintball bot
hinzugefügt werden
das sieht jetzt erst mal krass fiel aus
ist es aber gar nicht weil das jetzt zum
beispiel das einzige was hinzugefügt
wurde dieses rote das gleiche gibt es
dann nochmal für orange gelb grün blau
und lila am genauso wie hier oben die
ins tabus und die scanner für purple
orange red chips i lon für yello und
green g für green und jahr blut blut das
ganze ist hier auch bei den waffen auch
nochmal beschriftet also mit er dahinter
für rot also für red für orange und
alles mögliche und so weiter und so fort
wir haben hier pellets wir haben hier
revieren cyberwaffen long shot ganz ganz
normale pistolen remote sachen payne
brothers alles mögliche haben wir hier
und zwar das erste ist ich hab hier
alles schon ein bisschen abgeschottet
ist noch so ein blöder setzlingen den
kann ich mal kurz weg tun
das allererste was ihr machen müsst das
habe ich davon aus schon macht ihr nehmt
euch eine instanz platziert die irgendwo
macht da rechtsweg drauf ich bin jetzt
in der wand drin ist weiß nicht so toll
und dann habt ihr hier halt schon so
eine base aufgebaut eigentlich wenn ihr
die irgendwo hinsetzen da rächt sich
drauf macht dann halt da drin ich weiß
ich kann ich hier nochmal eine aufbauend
auf das funktioniert nicht und zwar
steht dann da nordin of space drive
einige maria wismeth
loks da kann mit den sachen einfach mal
weg machen rechts liegt dann wird hier
noch eine generiert na ja also das ist
so eine instanz die werden halt so
gebaut einfach normal von dem spiel der
mit zwei blaue das setzt natürlich
ungünstig weil blitz im gegensatz zu den
orangen da hinten in der unterzahl ist
aber naja ich versuche ich das trotz mal
zu zeigen und zwar wir hier die scanner
das ein ganz normale wie halt hier schon
gezeigt dass scanner
b das sind ganz normale tritt platten
wenn man darauf geht dann geht die tür
offen allerdings bin ich ja noch keinem
team deswegen haben wir hier eine kiste
drin da steht drin
webtrekk am reck mit paint blackboard
webtrekk am reck mit cambridge also
alles zweimal bis auf die flagge die
zielflagge brauchen halt manchmal weil
man eigentlich auch nur zu zweit spielt
er sich stellt die sachen jetzt immerhin
das medi kit da ich im creative not been
kommen die sachen jetzt auch bleiben
nicht aus dem inventar aus so das sind
nämlich erstmal so die sachen die euch
alle gegeben werden von cambridge
aber das ist eigentlich erst mal relativ
egal so und zwar erstmal damit ihr intim
kommt mittel auf einmal rechts weg
machen dann bekommen wir hier die armor
die kann man einfach hier anlegen und
zwar sehen wir nun so aus wie ein ganz
normaler paintball spieler halt ich weiß
nie wer von euch schon mal paintball
gespielt habe ich persönlich nicht würde
ich allerdings gerne machen allerdings
sieht so halt die rüstung dann auslands
eventim glaubt wenn wir nun auf diese
sachen drauf treten dann kommen wir hier
auch rein aber allerdings kommen wir nur
in die blauen gebäude rein und zwar
interagiert weil sie unsere blaue
rüstung damit diesen blauen platten
wenn ich hier auf ein orange gehen
können wir dann natürlich nicht einmal
das ist die base von dem orangen team
denkt jetzt bestimmt helfen dann team
also das es eigentlich für server
gedacht die mod die modifikation
deswegen habe ich auch gar kein gegner
team allerdings naja ich denke ihr wisst
was ich meine
und naja ich habe jetzt hier schon auf
medical drauf gedrückt das hat ein
bisschen doof und zwar wenn ihr
irgendwie verletzt seid oder so ich
drücke drauf dann seid ihr halt wieder
voll mit eurem leben
und ja hier ist halt auch die arme also
wenn eure als irgendwie kaputt ist oder
so könnt ihr hier auch die armor
auffüllen da seht ihr schon da das ist
ein bisschen runtergegangen und wir
kriegen jetzt einfach mal hier auf die
pistolen sachen das könnt ihr euch alles
nur einmal holen und dann haben wir halt
die pistolen
alle kurz ins inventar um euch das ein
bisschen zu zeigen und zwar fangen wir
einfach ganz einfach an wir haben hier
remote ich habe kürzlich hier brauche
ich den c4 c4 c4 c4 das zitiert und zwar
erst mal fangen wir mit c4 wir können
jetzt zum beispiel wenn da irgendwie
einer charta kenntnis kommt von hinten
an
die remote moment er hoffe dass jetzt
nicht helfen und connected wird also ich
weiß gar nicht was sie für ein fehler
ist und wie wir das c4 dazu knacken
können
das heißt ich habe ganz viel c4 remote
naja ich weiß nicht genau wie das
funktionieren soll aber okay also
eigentlich sollte es dann zu sein wenn
ihr rechtsweg drückt mit der remote
betastet dass ihr dann das seht ihr sage
ich mal auswählen könnt also ihr seht
auch schon c4 sowie travel das feld
halte runter jetzt funktioniert das
verstehe jetzt nicht ach so ich musste
ach so ich hab die ganze zeit rechts
gemacht das war das problem aber das hab
ich vergessen als ihr müsst ihr hin tun
dann mit der remote taste links liegt
auf der b49 connected to the remote wenn
er dann hinten in einer hin läuft und
dann explodiert das also ich hab das gar
nicht gehört aber naja also moment also
macht halt nur einen kleinen schaden und
macht halt in der umwelt allgemein
keinen schaden das ist eher unnötig
jetzt erstmal so allerdings wenn gegner
halt kommen dann macht das schon einen
gehörigen schaden
dann haben wir die pistole das ist ganz
einfach halten waffen womit ihnen
schlagen könnt ihr mit linksklick machen
dann könnt ihr alles zu schießen so
anvisieren dann macht ihr rechtsklick
rechtsklick schießen habe ich überhaupt
munition frage ich mich gerade rappen
records eigentlich habe ich an munition
naja dann haben wir noch eine sniper mit
der können wir auch ganz einfach schnell
wie ich schieße ich denn ich jetzt total
bescheuert naja ihr habt hier
verschiedene waffen mit dem schießen
könnt irgendwie charakters grad bei mir
alles ab die pfp es ein bisschen komisch
mit linksklick sind wir auf jeden fall
erstmal ran
wie genau ihr schießt das weiß ich
jedenfalls erstmal nicht könnt ihr mir
in die kommentare schreiben aber ich
verstehe nicht wieso ich hier nicht
schießen können habe ich keine munition
oder oder das ist jetzt jedes problem
sicherlich auf scharfe sich herzlich
moment moment das müsse doch mal ganz
kurz medicaid amore amore
ist aber auch portable player na ja ich
würde sagen machen weiter wie man mit
den sachen hier ab hier funktioniert
setzt wiederum mit dem schießen und
jetzt funktioniert ja so wie vorher aber
das problem ist gerade bei diesen sachen
funktioniert wenn ich hier mit skis
erwartet so sollte damit das
funktioniert perfekt
das ist klappt alles super aber bei den
anderen waffen klappt das nicht aussehen
wie ich oft bei minecraft charakter
könnte eigentlich selber ausprobieren
das hier sind wir ja jetzt auch schüler
in gruppen das hier sind granaten die
könnt ihr ganz deutschland töten könnt
ihr ganz einfach werfen mit rechtsklick
und dann explodieren die machen halt
auch ein gehörigen schaden also ich kann
jetzt im einlauf der schaffter werden
so das direktorium partner herein und
jetzt natürlich nicht viel weil er keine
blöcke explodieren können aber naja
und das letzte was es noch gibt es eine
play more und zwar haben wir hier noch
ein schaf und zwar wenn ich deine kleine
schätze mit einem thema hinter schafft
jetzt wird er unter schaaf bewegt sich
und läuft quasi dadurch hat die
wissenschaft ich versuche dass man also
her zu schützen babys ein explodierter
scharf wenn es dadurch läuft und zwar
wenn man selbst dadurch läuft passiert
nix und ihr könnt einfach drauf schlagen
bekommt ihr die sachen immer wieder so
das war's erst mal alles wir hier noch
eine flagge die könnte irgendwo
hinstellen und damit das gegnerische
team die flagge halt einnehmen und ihr
dann die flanke vom gegnerischen team
und die komplett meistens irgendwie
keine ahnung hier oben drauf oder so
oder halt irgendwo auf dem boden in der
nähe von eurer basis und naja das ist
auf jeden fall erstmal der paypal bot
ich hoffe ich konnte euch das ein
bisschen zeigen
trotzdem tut mir leid dafür dass wir so
ein paar sachen nicht geklappt haben wie
zum beispiel das schießen mit dem sniper
gewehr habe ich echt keine ahnung warum
das nicht funktioniert hat oder ob ich
da ganz einfach jetzt genug munition für
braucht oder naja ich weiß nicht woran
das liegt typen auf jeden fall freuen
dass das mit der sniper nicht so ganz
geklappt habe ich es zeigen wollte
allerdings kann ich euch sagen die
kneipe ist das beste gewähren den
kompletten spiel also ein schuss und der
gegner ist tot und geht hat auch auf
lange entfernung also kandidat von hier
bis dahin der tür hin zoom und der sind
an einem halt drauf ich höre ich
irgendwas laufen
es sind dann auch langsam wieder zurück
also es ist ganz cool gemacht so ja das
war der beim paintball bot ich würde dem
paintball watch einfach immer wieder ein
paar zu bewerten
ich würde dem mod eigentlich bzw der
mord heißt ist ja ich sage ich würde den
mod eigentlich neun von zehn punkten
geben da naja also eigentlich jahrzehnt
von 10 5 und 10 weil der einzige fehler
der mir aufgefallen ist wenn man diese
sachen also wartet mache ich zeige euch
das mal
diesem beispiel ich kann hier zum
beispiel keinen links hin bauen und was
mich wünschen würde wenn war
denn diese gras teile da nicht mit
einberechnet werden weil wenn ich
erzähle die bäume weg kloppe und ein
sohn gras busch ding hier steht dann
wird erhält wird das ding nicht gebaut
das häuschen weil dieses gras bush teil
der halt steht das ist halt ein bisschen
doof
naja das ist halt erstmal die
modifikation paintball und ja download
facebook wird das als eine beschreibung
wird mich über einen daumen hoch freuen
und dann sehen wir uns beim nächsten mal
freunde